schon wieder eine spektakuläre
überraschungen die in diesem fall der
stern beta pictoris da für uns bereit
hält eine neue studie hat nämlich jetzt
enthüllt dass dieser massereiche
blutjunge stern nicht nur von einem
sondern sogar von mindestens zwei
gigantischen planeten umkreist wird wie
können wir uns beta pictoris b
vorstellen und wie gelangen diese
überraschende entdeckung tricks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen der massereichen stern beta
pictoris ist so jung dass ich seine
entstehung mit dem menschlichen
stammbaum abgleichen lässt der stern der
etwa 63 lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist
und sich im sternbild des malers viktor
befindet wurde vor etwa 20 bis 23
millionen jahren geboren im vergleich
mit der sonne die in etwa 4,6 milliarden
jahren alt ist ist es wirklich extrem
jung als beta pictoris also geboren
wurde trennten sich auf der erde gerade
die sogenannten menschenartigen also die
gibbons menschenaffen und unsere
direkten vorfahren vom rest der primaten
ab diese epd geschichtliche epoche wird
in der fachsprache auch als mini 10
bezeichnet und weil beta pictoris ebenso
blutjung ist hat der massereiche sterne
schon für manche überraschung gesorgt
die astronomen annemarie waggons
bezeichnet ist als das wahrscheinlich
beste planetensystem das werk kennen um
die frühen stadien der bildung und
entwicklung solcher systeme zu
erforschen
in den 80er jahren schon gelang hast du
nie teams eine echte premiere
sie konnten eine aufnahme anfertigen die
erstmalig den nachweis der sogenannten
protoplanetaren scheibe ermöglichte ein
großer meilenstein für die astronomie
solch ringförmige scheiben aus gas und
staub befinden sich um sehr junge sterne
herum
aus ihr können sich mit der zeit
planeten entwickeln auch unsere erde und
ihre nachbarn sind mal aus solch einer
rotierenden scheibe aus gas und staub um
die jungen sonne entstanden 2009 sorgte
beta pictoris für die zweite sensation
denn damals wurde in diesen sternsystem
ein erster planeten entdeckt beta
pictoris b
ein wirklich großer borken jetzt hat ein
französisches astronomie team für eine
weitere überraschung gesorgt denn den
fachleuten ist es gelungen
einen weiteren planeten um beta pictoris
aufzuspüren
sein name beta pictoris c laut der
studie handelt es sich auch bei ihm um
einen gewaltigen brocken so weist der
etwa achtung die 3000 fache erdmasse auf
wort zum vergleich jupiter der fünfte
und größte planet unseres sonnensystems
bringt es gerade einmal auf steinert 18
erdmassen und noch mehr konnten die
fachleute bereits über den neu
entdeckten planeten herausfinden er ist
wohl 2,7 mal so weit von seinem stern
beta pictoris entfernt wie die erde von
der sonne um seinen stern zu umrunden
braucht der 1200 tage
bedingt durch die hohe rotation um seine
eigene achse dauert einen tag auf dem
neu entdeckten planeten nur knapp acht
stunden die spektakuläre entdeckung
wurde durch die sogenannten
radialgeschwindigkeit methode möglich
diese methode eignet sich sehr gut um
planeten zu entdecken
auch die hinweise bezüglich eines
zweiten planeten und proxima centauri
konnten damit erst vor kurzem aufgespürt
werden
wir haben darüber hierbei klick zum
science fiction berichtet dafür wird die
radial geschwindigkeit der sterne in
bezug zur erde gemessen um die
hypothetischen planeten kreisen könnten
in bestimmten zeitlichen abständen
werden dafür hoch aufgelöste spektren
des sterns aufgenommen denn durch die
zusammensetzung eines sterns und seinen
licht erzeugen prozessen entstehen ganz
charakteristische spektren daraus können
fachleute dann sogenannte doppler
verschiebungen erkennen die wiederum
rückschlüsse auf die mögliche existenz
eines planeten zu lassen denn der
radialgeschwindigkeit in bezug zur erde
kann immer sehr genau bestimmt werden
kreis ein planet um einen stern taumelt
der sterne in bezug zur erde durch
dieses taumeln können dann planeten
aufgespürt werden weiterhin sind die
analyse durch messungen des harps
spektrografen das la silla
observatoriums eingeflossen und das
forschungsteam ist optimistisch dass
noch weitere spannende entdeckungen
folgen werden denn auch die esa
raumsonde gaia und das extremely large
telescope in chile sollen das junge
system und beta pictoris demnächst
genauer ins visier nehmen wahnsinn erst
60 gramm und entdeckt wird das wird
immer absolut spektakulärer also an
kriegen anschauen und us comics tv
abonnieren einer meiner absoluten
lieblings kanäle bis dann bleibt dran